みなさんこんにちはー
安積社長です皆さんさっき運動してますでしょうか
だんだん暑くなってきて皆さんのウィンドウ佐伯てて皆さんと思うんですけども
さて変動したい季節皆さんどういう運動されますでしょうかやっぱり運動されなら
楽しい運動がいいと思うんですよ
そこで誰でも簡単にできるスポーツその中でも一番手っ取りばいいと思ったものが反復
やボタン
スポーツ性とで皆さんもやってもらえると
もんですよあんとっ
あるんですよねアン付横跳びのやり方の説明をしますパック4個と人はまず100cm
の感覚で栄光に光ですが来ての中温泉をまたいでたくさん
合図と同時に自分の右側にサイドステップ教えて右側ないように癒しをコインから員に
触れたらギーは左に再度説法せ中労委に戻ります
また左右左右ってペン絆
法案って創生を経てまた口だけですこうやってこれは100センチ感が中将のルールだ
と20秒間で何回それができるかというのは数えられるんですけどもずっと高速なんで
今私を部の足台パンっていうことでいい
1万回何秒でできるのかな通常はその20秒間やってなんか何回できればいいみたいな
感じなんですけどもお腹違う山にしてしまいますよね10秒間かそういうのじゃなくて
一番会を何秒でできるかとそのチームもたいできるのかどうかっていう体力的な面も
考えてる女ない部分がたくさんあるんですけどなんか反復横跳びってもうちょっとなめ
てるんですよ
クソ簡単じゃないですかって個入ってた
ということであった
構成滝通していて話だねこれに授業前とその記されないんでこれ1万円あればどれ
くらい使え疲れるの
このエジョンがやるとどれくらい疲れるのがぜと一番が減ると何秒くらい変わるの
かってともうちょっと早く見たいと思いますこれが多分全国の男子処分の平均ために
なるので皆さん
参考にやってみてくださいじゃあゼミします結構やなぁこんなあった家で
ってゼロってことでしょ
まず一番回ちょっと脂を話していただけでしょなんて本当に1万回か旋回でよかって
おきます
ピアース反復横跳び一番効8位
スタートん
voodoo
まず yamachan あのページャー女神でた
ブーブー5
姉ちゃんっ
[拍手]
んまってまじゃないこれ詰んだ選挙だった
まず本当にごめんねこれではまず交えたこれ一番カフェだ
[音楽]
ます
まじゃあねーよねー全部見る
[音楽]
45おいて夜中
良い中でずっと本当に相当な
800バイクじゃこれ
ねっちクイズ
今回ミスター通りじゃ私が骨を折りました
はこれやります
[音楽]
どこ行ってきました
結構 web で200ポイントプレゼント
ああああああああああっ
[音楽]
これ結構恋愛や俺
骨がベッツプラン
却下見えた見えた魅せろここに体は
方向夫婦が住んで売ってる商品が美人で身体を一番上に固定していうことによってあっ
て
傷でさぁ
a 4判16ページ
グー
par
者ジャックやがー
[拍手]
[音楽]
以前タイルってえーっ
旋回きました
タイバー
12分30秒
うん
グリッ
me
あまりだ本当にいいです
あのってだけでずに府南部設計を依頼させてい
ネット外れセゾンなぁ
反響ドック the 線回数がー
10年ですっちゅう中35でしたあっ本当に食べこれ一番かやると運動してない人はか
別に死ぬんですけど運動してる人もそこそこ動けなくなっちゃうと思うんで
旋回にしときましょう一番街バハ行くと時間に余裕がある時でやろうと思います
[音楽]